Mí không qua cho biết ổ sân bay U.S. à praar hâm liền khuôn cung cấp tổ hổ tổng, đã đến trung đồng.
Lần thái này diễn ra trong mối cảnh trang thẳng đăng rào tăng, giống mí, bả y ra.
Tổng thống Mỹ đô nên tróng hẳng định, lượng lượng quân sự nước này chín khai ở gần i ra,
hiện đã vượt qua quy mô của lượng màn lâu nông các tụng điều động luyến khu vực ngoài hơn vinh này rùi là.
Phản lượng chức động thái này, i ra tẩy báo sịch có phản lượng toàn dịnh trước mất kỳ hành động tình công nào.
Lượng thơi coi mọi cuộc tấn công là một lượng thái hơi mào cho chín chanh tổng lực.
Theo người phân hôn định Kremlin đi mitree pe scoff, ngà mông muốn tất cả các bên linh qua sạch kiểm chiế,
tập trung hoàn toàn và các cuộc nằm phản hoa bình, để gài quế tóc vấn đề của lỗi.
Vì phần mình tổng thức kiế tổ chức hiệu ước mắt đại tây dương mắt hút tờ cho biết,
nát tôi sẽ không căn dự và tình hình tại Iran, bởi lý mình này đang tập trung vào hùi vực trộn đại tây dương.
Chong từ gồm mới nhất, các tự vốn qua ở rật thống nhất hẳn định sẽ không cho phép sự dụng lãnh thổ của mình cho bất kỳ hành động quân sự thủ định nào nhằm vào Iran.